-Welcome back!
-You just said,
"Jim, I like you
more than I like John Mulaney."
-I did.
I whispered that to you.
-And I thought that was special.
-That was a nice thing
to tell you.
-That was
a nice adjustment there.
-I do want to ask this
right off the bat.
We talked last time
you were here about --
your wonderful wife, Jeannie,
had a brain tumor.
-Yeah.
-She's doing better.
-She is doing great.
You know,
once they remove a tumor
the size of a pear
from your head,
you're not, you know,
back to 100%,
but she's great.
She's --
You know,
she's taking kids to school.
She's writing a book about it.
She's doing great.
-Obviously,
you told jokes about it.
-Yes.
-How has that been?
Has that been
a cathartic experience,
being able
to process it that way?
-It's amazing.
You know, yeah.
I mean, my wife and I,
we write everything together.
And to do those jokes,
I was kind of surprised,
because, initially,
I was like,
"All right,
I'm talking about my wife
going through
this medical emergency."
But what I realized is that,
as I toured,
everyone spent those
two-odd weeks in a hospital.
We don't want
to live in that memory,
but we identify
with that memory.
So, yeah, it was great.
It was very cathartic.
-This is very exciting.
Because outside of stand-up,
you also are an actor --
a wonderful one, by my count --
and you have three films
that are gonna be
premiering at Sundance.
-I am like the Parker Posey...
-Wow!
-...of Sundance.
-You're the new Parker Posey.
-What is unique
about these films --
It's like,
I normally don't look like this.
I gained 80 pounds...
[ Laughter ]
...for each of those films.
-So, it just worked out
that all three roles
asked you to gain 80 pounds.
-It's an amazing coincidence.
[ Laughter ]
It's an amazing coincidence.
Like, in the script,
they're like,
"Very overweight,
super-hot guy."
[ Laughter ]
And it worked out.
No, but it is so exciting to --
You know,
'cause I've been acting in stuff
for 25, 30 years.
And so to have --
You know, Sundance is
the be-all, you know, thing.
So to go there
with three films is amazing,
and these are great films,
so I'm excited.
-And you got to work
with some really great actors.
-Yeah, it's amazing.
Like Olivia Colman,
Walton Goggins, Viola Davis,
Allison Janney.
It's amazing.
-And they were all asked to stay
at their current weights?
[ Laughter ]
-They were all --
They're like --
They were all asked to stay --
They were like, "Look,
you guys focus on the lines.
Jim can do multiple things."
[ Laughter ]
But it's --
I mean, I could list --
There's so many amazing actors.
Marin Ireland,
who is in an off-Broadway show.
I do a film with her.
There's an amazing --
I could list every actor,
and I probably should,
but I won't.
-Well, congratulations on that.
That's very exciting.
You've talked --
[ Applause ]
-Yeah, give it up!
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
You can gain this weight, too!
-[ Laughing ]
-You can gain this weight
if you try.
[ Laughter ]
If you have a commitment.
-You talked about this, as well.
And I'm very --
I look forward to my kids
being old enough
for this to be an option,
but you have been touring
internationally.
-Yes.
-And using it as an opportunity
to bring all five of your
children with you on vacations.
-Yes.
Well, you know, jet lag is fun,
but jet lag with a 6-year-old
with jet lag is better.
-Yeah.
-No, I --
I love, you know,
touring, doing stand-up.
You know,
we've done many shows together.
And so, like,
doing these international shows,
they're an amazing opportunity.
And also, it's --
You know, so at Thanksgiving,
I was in Athens.
I brought my kids
to the Parthenon.
I'm not Greek.
I know I look Greek,
but I'm not.
[ Laughter ]
And so we tooled around Athens
a little bit,
and then I did a show,
and it's amazing.
-And you took a Greek dance
class with your children?
-We took a Greek dance --
I thought it was gonna be, like,
in a restaurant,
and my kids were gonna dance,
and I was gonna eat a gyro,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
But we showed up, and it was,
like, in a dance studio,
and we did, you know,
some of these dances.
And then they said,
"All right, now let's get in
the traditional Greek outfits,
and I was like, "Okay."
And so --
-And it's fantastic.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yes.
-I will say...
Even if you
took this photo in color,
I feel like it would come out
in black-and-white.
[ Laughter ]
-It was so amazing, because I
know I look like a great dancer,
but I'm not.
[ Laughter ]
And I was resistant,
but it was an amazing experience
to do with your kids.
-And are your children at the
age now where they're laughing
at you being a bad dancer?
-Oh, they laugh at me
just about everything.
But there is something
about seeing me dance that bad
where they're like, "Oh,
you're really not good at this."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Are you a good dancer?
-No.
-'Cause, you know, like,
in the acting and improv
and stuff like that,
there's moments
where you'll see someone --
You're like, "Oh, wow.
You can't dance at all."
And I'm one of those people
that can't.
[ Laughter ]
-You also went to South Africa.
-Went to South Africa.
-How was that?
-Amazing.
You know, we went on a safari,
which is essentially just a
fancy word for animal stalking.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-That's all you do.
You just kind of, like,
follow around animals.
And it's a good thing they can't
turn you in to the police.
Because they would be like,
"That bald guy over there
was following me for two hours."
[ Laughter ]
"And then, when I woke up,
he was taking pictures of me
and my family,
and we were naked."
[ Laughter ]
You know? It's --
It's a very strange thing.
But it is -- it's fascinating.
It's hard to articulate,
because you sit there,
and it is the circle of life.
So, like, you'll sometimes see
an animal kill another animal,
and intellectually, you think,
"Oh, I don't want to see that,"
but when you're in the moment,
you're like, "Get 'em."
[ Laughter ]
Even my 9-year-old daughter,
who loves animals,
draws pictures of kittens
all of the time,
She's like, "Get 'em, get 'em!"
[ Laughter ]
It was funny.